[Music]
[Applause]
no no no no you look amazing you look
fantastic you know i just read that
intro for you and uh we're friends so i
know that you're doing a lot
but it just sounds like you can't say no
to anything they they call you up and
you say yes i offer me a job i will take
it yeah yeah anybody that's a dangerous
thing to say a people pleaser yeah i'm
such a bad people pleaser it's crazy i
just don't know when to now just
professionally like no no it bleeds into
my personal life of natch um and uh i
was in oh gosh i was in oklahoma city
because that's where i grew up and i was
visiting my mom and
um i went to the only like natural foods
grocery store there
you know just an ordinary day and i
walked in and they have these um like
middle-aged women who are like greeters
i don't know why at the grocery store
but anyway this woman's standing there
and
i said she said hello i said hello and
she said wait a minute
has anyone ever told you that you look
like and i said i
save you the trouble i i'm i'm her i'm
the lady you're probably thinking of the
lady from william grace that's me she's
like no you're not
[Laughter]
and i said oh yeah i know i am i'm i'm
the i'm just here i grew up here i'm
visiting my mom she goes
no
no
and i said well okay i mean um i am but
that's okay she goes show me some
identification
and i and i said okay
and i reached into my purse and i pulled
out a credit card and she goes i need a
photo id
and i was like oh let me get it let me
get it and right around then i was like
what am i doing yeah
what am i doing you know who you are
bending over backwards to prove to this
woman in the grocery store like the
greeter at the natural food store in
oklahoma city that i was on will and
grace well it's just and right now right
now that woman is saying i met her and
she's kind of cold
she doesn't have a very good driver's
license yeah her picture really isn't
very good
you have this new show with christian
slater uh called breaking in and we have
a clip to show is there anything you can
tell us about oh i'm the new boss of
this company and i am
in a sort of a war with christian slater
and so i'm i've come to this event to
sort of one-up him okay let's this uh
clip from uh breaking in
first of all don't panic diamond bra
doesn't get up and just walk away
[Applause]
[Applause]
what is she doing up there
i believe she's teaching me a lesson
about who's in charge
and
upload it
funny